How Do We Name An Angle Consider This Angle Which
Is Formed By Ray B And Ray B S
Assume It's An Acute Angle With The Measure Of
Degree Even Times The Measure Of The Angles Are
Not Given And Variable Au Small Case Letters
Are Used Instead
Like  So the variable b would be equal to
degrees even times even Greek symbols like
theta aa
used in this case theta would be equal to 60
degrees The letters b and theta are generally just
used for convenience but how do we
name the angles what angle is  60
degrees let me zoom out and draw this angle this
angle can be called angle a b s this
sign which looks like an acute angle is
used to represent an angle
we use the order from top to bottom a to b
to c so we can  Say that the measure of angle a
is
60° even times this angle is also referred to as just angle
b The letter we use here is the
vertex of the angle and the point b is
common to both the rays This one letter notation to
name  The angle is convenient but is not
preferred Let's see why look at this figure Here writing
just angle b will not work
since this vertex does not have just one angle if we say angle
b we will not know if we are talking about
angle AD and angle  dB s
and may be even angle as s so it is always better to write
the name of the angle using the three
letter
notation